hey I have to tell you speaking of
Herschel Walker some of you may or may
not know Herschel Walker's son Christian
Walker is also a right-winger he's also
a social media influencer
and he turned against his father
Herschel Walker for being an absent dad
and for endangering him and his mom and
so many different things Herschel
Walker's son Christian Walker actually
made a lot of sense talking about Donald
Trump's endorsement record and this does
not mean that I now agree with Christian
Walker's worldview or anything like it
but on this particular issue Christian
Walker correctly assesses the absurdity
of the endorsement record that Donald
Trump is touting take a listen to this
y'all stop with this endorsement lie if
I endorse Ron DeSantis a week before his
election could I go see he won because
of me no he was gonna win anyways he was
gonna win it's a Florida and he's done a
great job just like if I win and endorse
a republican in Alabama and was like see
my endorsements are amazing right no I'm
pretty sure Republican was gonna win in
Alabama right just like if a Democrat
endorsed Gavin Newsom he he's gonna win
done and endure you get to you get to
brag about your endorsements in toss-up
States or whatever that's what we're
that's what I'm looking for did your
endorsements win in toss-up states where
we had a chance then lost or then won
you got your brag about endorsements if
you have a republican win in a blue
state but not Republicans in seats we've
had for decades this is spot on and I
have to say I'm glad that there is a
right winger including an extremist
right winger like Christian Walker
who is saying this when Trump and other
pro-trump Republicans talk about listen
209 was the record or maybe now it's 250
and 15 or whatever what matters are the
contested elections of consequence okay
DeSantis was winning by 12. in the polls
ultimately won by 19. Trump held off on
saying almost anything about DeSantis
until the very end didn't even invite
him to his rally the Sunday before the
election and counts DeSantis as one of
his wins what matters is whether you can
deliver victories either when there is a
contested primary and you influence the
primary and subsequently the person you
choose goes on to win or whether you can
influence a toss-up state
he endorsed Mehmet Oz Trump did and Oz
lost
he endorsed Doug mastriano and mastriano
lost that was a critical race of
significant importance he endorsed Tudor
Dixon in Michigan for governor and
Gretchen Whitmer one he endorsed Blake
Masters an important senate seat in
Arizona Mark Kelly won he endorsed
Carrie Lake it looks like Kerry lake is
going to lose he endorsed J.R Majewski
and John Gibbs both of whom I
interviewed check out those interviews
in their respective congressional
districts they both lost those are the
endorsements that are actually relevant
endorsing incumbents
republican nominees in safe seats
waiting until the last minute when
you've already seen how all the polling
shakes out there's nothing remarkable
about that whatsoever by the way one
more I I was curious how is Christian
Walker reacting to what's going on in
Georgia because his own father is now in
a runoff election against Rafael Warnock
there take a listen
so is everyone saying we had a great
midterm season we just lost the Senate
before we even get to the Georgia runoff
so even if we win Georgia we've already
lost because if we win Georgia it would
go to a tie and the vice president is
the tiebreaker and she's a demo accurate
explanation of how the Senate works very
good so for everyone celebrating the
midterm saying we did so good
congratulations we lost congratulations
hope you expect us to celebrate you
think you can Gaslight everyone into
saying we had a great midterms we lost
very easy seats to pick up we couldn't
easily won
good job tired of all this winning no
I'm sick of losing okay so Christian
Walker shot out of a cannon there and a
lot of what he's been saying lately
really does make sense he will not be
campaigning for his father Herschel
Walker we will certainly be working for
Raphael Warnock and um I uh we're still
taking ideas for what we should do
should we do a sort of fundraiser
Telethon live stream where the more
money we raise for Warnock the longer
the stream goes should we do I don't
know what the privacy rules would be
around some kind of live phone banking I
just don't know we're trying to figure
it out but if you have ideas of how to
ensure
that Democrats get 51 seats rather than
just the 50 and make Joe manchin
irrelevant email info davidpackman.com